talk to you gentlemen but modifications
mmm modifications for video games I
don't know where this came from I think
there might have been a reddit thread
maybe during the week mods have been on
my mind since over watch because I've
been sort of thinking about all the
weird little directions first person
shooters renton and we talked about
battlefield on here last week and we
were talking about you know some of the
mods that came from there and had I fed
back into battlefield and I was just
sort of had this idea of like just
having a talk about some of the mods
that have been the most influential and
in terms of the sort of lasting
impression they had on video games after
the fact Ben what is like your favorite
module it's like the biggest most
impactful mod you think he played well
the one that sticks out for me or the in
terms of my memories I played the most
and was day of defeat right was way back
in the half life one day it's like 99
yeah there's no something um and I'm
really preceded a lot of the kind of
world war two first-person shooters it
was really before a lot of that stuff
came through quite a long time before
any of that stuff came through and
particularly the normandy beach landing
levels of though of that mod was
something that became at the office i
was working at the time like just a huge
deal i would status what we will play
every day you know played a little bit
of action quake and some rice things at
that time but encounter strike obviously
but that mod day of the fee was was was
the one and so yeah now that that one
for me would be will be a would be
blowing pay ya half-life was a that
engine seemed to spawn mod after mile
after Marge I mean we had team fortress
classic which obviously you know goes
back to quake quake world team fortress
before that and but obviously that had a
massive sort of that whole class based
online shooter you know every one of
them can go back to that and we're
seeing that an overwatch a lot now
whereas you know it's it's essentially a
classmate shooter but instead of just
five or six different classes you've now
got this crazy 21 I mean people look at
it and look at MOBAs and they go oh it's
that hero thing would it's like a direct
evolution of what's happened there and
Peter what are some of the mods that you
sort of enjoyed playing growing up I
guess you were mostly a console gamer
growing up so so the most part yeah I
mean like I played a bunch of pc games
but the one mod I will never forget
Randy Savage sky the most impactful mod
of them all yeah no I mean yes so for me
because I still in prime airily a
console gamer the way I look at Maude's
is sort of evidence of how great and
passionate the gaming community can be
and I may not play DotA right I may not
play counter-strike but I can really
appreciate the sort of the time and
energy that people put into this in the
enjoyment they get out of it mmm it
makes me wish that I had more time to be
involved in it to be honest with you so
to hear you guys like you know hear you
talk about that look with such passion
it's like that's a game that is only
possible because of the fans and here it
is sort of coming full circle it was it
was purely out of people really wanted
to play a World War two yeah shooter
right and it was because it was around
that time the saving private ryan and
come out like people really nice
experience that wasn't that map
particularly the normandy beach landing
map on their defeat was you know it was
an attempt it was purely like what can
we do to kind of encapsulate what we're
loving in the movies at that time I
think Skyrim is a really good pic though
because I I think in terms of
popularizing mods I mean some of the
oblivion mods were pretty awesome
actually some of the modding that was
going on there but really you know
Bethesda's foresight to really include
and encourage morning the way they've
done has completely changed the
landscape right i mean not just from
stupid mods like the chicken mods and
yeah and the and the Macho Man Randy
Savage mods but like level creation the
entire mapping of morrowind right yeah
all of this kind of crazy stuff that
comes from that absolute passion I'm
gonna be very interesting to see how
Skyrim or I'm I'll fall out and do it on
console real soon in because a lot of
that stuff involves you know I mean
anyone is install of the skyrim mods
knows how much it chugs your PC even if
you're running Skyrim now on a very
beefy pc you start stacking those mods
in there it slows that thing down pretty
quickly so i don't know it's gonna be
interesting to see what they will they
do this that's weird it's like this
strange little incubator for creativity
that you don't usually get in games cuz
games like take so long to develop like
their ideas do you don't see the end
result off for like two or three years
later but mods allow people to like just
like tweak with rules a little bit and
sort of make interesting you know like
you said like data
wasn't the most polished thing ever when
I first came out and then you look at
things like you know desert combat for
battlefield 1942 which was again when I
first came out it was pretty rough
around the edges but then that game ends
up inspiring them to go back and
basically do battlefield 2 which was
Desert Combat yeah well it's crime
sinkers like game designers and game
developers modding is quite antithetical
to what they do right they they have
every right to be very protective and
proud of my creation and don't
necessarily want us as fans messing
around with what they've created and
that's why I think someone like Todd
Howard's incredibly progressive in or be
no because he builds an open-world
sandbox but he also invites the
community to come in and change that
sandbox and do the most ridiculous
things with it you know a lot of game
creators it's it's not in their nature
to do that they're presenting to you
something that they've crafted and
created and so you know that sort of
shift from your modding used to be sort
of black the dark side you know Iser
people doing it sort of without the
knowledge you know in particular on the
pc would they were just taking it into
their own hands for it to actually be
encouraged and become part of the game
cycle is something pretty incoming yeah
it's progressive one of my favorite
modelling stories it comes from one of
my favorite game series I guess Unreal
Tournament 2003 there was a mod that was
made for that where I think it was like
one of the background files there was
like some sort of textures for trucks
and cars and stuff and then the modding
community got a hold of it and started
like building these like car games
within it and and then some of those
people including I think David Hage
would were brought into the fold at epic
and they were like all right with these
cars let's make a mode out of it and
that was unreal tournament 2004 s
onslaught mode and then he eventually
left epic started his own company called
psionics and then last year we got
rocket League which is basically the
like natural evolution of that because
all these weird football mods came out
for soccer mods came out for verano
Terim and sort of in the interim not
something that happened over the course
of length 15 here using your recent
piece on over watch the video i shot
down a blizzard that those guys talking
about how a lot of the map designers and
those guys didn't come out of designing
necessarily at studios they came out
developing maps for the action quake
community and actually out of the
modding community a very much grass
level of devant of designing FPS stuff
yeah it's strange out like the sort of
seeds that get blunted eventually sort
of blossom years later and I've got I
just thought of something you guys
walking so before I miss my opportunity
one of the best games from last year was
super mario maker right yeah right but
years before Nintendo was doing that
there was a website called smw central
dotnet people been hacking roms for a
long time but this website catered to a
really hard core audience of people who
modified super mario world and they
created editing engines multiple
versions of them like over the years to
allow this to happen and some of the
games people made are in my opinion may
be better than super mario world at
certain points so console gamers
actually had that you even had people
then taking burning eproms putting them
on circuit boards making cartridges of
their favorite Super Mario mods but then
you seem crazy follow suit and they
release their easy it would marry my god
the perfect example of how far modding
has come right intend oh yeah the most
protective company totally you can ever
imagine would build a game which is just
a modding tool for their biggest IP
their biggest license yeah it is isn't
is would have been impossible to think
of happening ten years ago I think you
know and we can talk about mods and the
impact they've had in the industry
without talking about a certain Warcraft
3 mod though I mean like dota is
probably the the poster child for what
can happen if you if you mod something
and come up with a unique idea and it
sort of follow through to its end point
and I mean dota was like a popular
defense of the ancients was a popular
mods within certain communities for a
long time in the same way data fee
probably was where I had a very sort of
core passionate group of people who were
very very into it for a long long long
time before we saw the sort of explosion
with obviously league of legends and
then eventually the I guess the rebirth
of dota through valve it's very easy to
forget that that's the origins of right
Moke the modern mobile that it comes
from a modding community and it again it
shows how far that stuff has come that
now we have things like a league of
legends and starcraft norman and dota 2
and we forget about the origins of the
mobile stuff but yeah it's crazy and
then sort of following on from some of
what we saw with with half-life
off life to also had a large modding
community coming at Ash and natural
selection 2 came out which was a I guess
that was actually an original half-life
mod as well and they sort of just made a
new version of it garry's mod that's
gonna skyre smart as well of course got
it didn't even have it on the list you
of course doesn't he make like a million
dollars a day off that let's do I don't
know but yeah at some point my in too
much they don't like his new game I have
friends who the ortho is really a bit of
a backlash about it at the moment her
friends of ours have got teenage kids
like 13-14 the things they play they
play Minecraft and they play garry's mod
it's mental and if he never played half
life no no no I can tell you absolutely
that the kids I spoke to who I was
chatting to about Gary because I was
just maxin aided by the fact that they
were playing Gary's more than that's all
they wanted to talk about was they'd
never played half life one that never
played on 52 and yet garry's mod is
something which is life in post play
games so yeah it's it's really strange
because like some of the biggest like
with half-life ones all these massive
multiplayer online sort of connected
world you know connective online
shooters came out of that but there were
half life two what we actually saw was
like the walking simulator genre sort of
burst out of it like games like dear
Esther and the stanley parable and which
sort of then birth their own little
sub-genre even portal essentially right
was wrong skeleton of half-life to write
me yeah like Naraku ler drop was a kind
of a was a digipen game and then yeah
they sort of fine okay can you do that
with this engine do we have I mean I
think they probably wanted source to or
whatever or that version of source which
is just a I mean source still to this
day has pieces of quake code in it and
but like I think they probably wanted
out to be more of a modding tool then it
ended up sort of becoming I'm oddly
enough yeah I mean they they they start
they released that I mean it was in the
wake of Skyrim I like portal to that
they really tried to encourage Steam
Workshop and stuff I never really caught
fire remember that time we were doing
the skyrim mod show on games bill right
over in the UK and we were as steam
workshop was expanding well i will let
what else can we roll in and my paul to
felt like the obvious next big thing in
terms of modding but it now seems very
near never really seemed to catch fire
in the same way it's weird
no it's hard to predict yeah totally as
hard to protect I couldn't I was even
surprised when can or strike came back
and I'm like a huge counter-strike fans
but like when when source came out like
even then there was this bus massive
backlash and some people never came off
1.6 but csgo I don't know what happened
like they had a new generation or
something but that just completely took
off all over again so it's really hard
to sort of tell especially these full
conversion mods and we're seeing less
and less of them and yeah so I guess
having a look at that and as loads we
haven't talked about I think about games
like you know Red Orchestra like science
and industry i remember in half-life 1
and there's so many of these masks come
out if we were to say what was the most
influential mod that has ever been made
of pure to pick well i think you
probably have to go with Dawn of the
Ancients right just a defense that sort
defense simply because we're what it's
led to I mean it I mean there's nothing
there there's nothing else which you in
completely create a completely new
gaming genre tically one which has taken
over an industry and high industry right
so it's like I mean III see the mobile
industry and you know competitive gaming
now as a result sitting next to what we
traditionally cover and think of as
games i mean i don't think the two
audiences really cross over maybe as
often as we'd like yeah you know um and
there's a lot of money to be made and a
lot of people who have a lot of jobs
yeah I know as a result of this like
it's it's intense you see like some of
the venues these guys fill like the
numbers they bring in all because some
guy had that idea one day like hey I'm
gonna screw with warcraft 3 yeah and
it's and consistently it's not even like
a we've seen would say starcraft or were
some other vino FPS is where they've had
their time in the sun and then they've
gone away again but DotA's been around
here for a good decent mountain seems to
continue building so yeah I'd love to be
able to say kind of strike but probably
use dota anyway we can go play that some
other time and let us know in the chat
what you think is the most influential
mod of all time is a dota is it
something else is there a weird mod that
we didn't mention at all either you'd
like to get some eyes on and put it the
comments below
Oh